what is the meaning and purpose of life
yeah that's a big question
i'll give you three and again because
there's a big question i'll give you
three answers uh
one is it's personal you have to find
your own meaning any piece of wisdom
that anybody else gives you whether it's
buddha or you or me it's gonna sound
like nonsense so i think fundamentally
you just have to find for yourself so
the important part is not the answer
it's the question you just have to sit
there and dig with a question and it
might take you years or decades but when
you find an answer you're happy with
that would be fundamental to your life
uh the second
answer i would give is there is no
meaning to life there's no purpose to
life
uh osho says it's like riding on water
uh or building houses in sand uh the
reality is you've been dead for the
history of the universe where 10 billion
years or more you will be for the next
70 billion years or so until the heat
that the universe and anything you do
will fade it will disappear just like
the human race will disappear the planet
will disappear get to mars even that
group will disappear so no one's going
to remember you past a certain number of
generations whether you're an artist or
a poet or a conqueror or a pauper or
nothing so there's no meaning
so you have to create your own meaning
which is what it boils down to you have
to decide is this a play that i'm going
through that i'm just watching is there
a
self-actualization dance that i'm doing
is there a specific thing that i just
desire just for the heck of it but these
are all meanings you are making up
there's no fundamental intrinsic
purposeful meaning to the universe
because if there was then you would just
ask the next question yourself well why
is that the meaning right so it would
just be as richard feynman said it'd be
turtles all the way down the y's would
just keep accumulating there is no
answer you can give that question that
wouldn't have another why and i don't
buy the everlasting afterlife answers
because it seems insane to me with
absolutely no evidence to believe that
because of how you live 70 years here on
this planet that you're going to spend
an eternity which is a very long time in
some afterlife what kind of silly god
judges you for eternity based on some
small period of time here um so i think
that after this life it's very much like
before you were born remember that it's
going to be just like that
and
and
but before you were born you didn't care
about anything or anyone including your
loved ones including yourself including
humans including whether we go to mars
or whether we stay on planet earth and
whether there's an ai or not you just
don't care so like i met this
entrepreneur who was obsessed with steve
jobs and he was making all these
sacrifices trying to be like the next
steve jobs and i said tim do you want to
be exactly like steve jobs right now he
said yes and i said well steve jobs is
dead he doesn't care about anything
he's gone like zero he's not registering
at all so if you want to be like steve
jobs you don't want to be like steve
jobs just be you right now he would
trade places with you right now in an
instant if you could
um so
i i don't think there's any real meaning
or purpose to life just to be here
[Music]
forget about any purpose life cannot
have any purpose
[Music]
life is the purpose
[Music]
how it can have any other purpose
[Music]
otherwise you will be in an
infinite regress
then that purpose will have another
purpose
then that another purpose will have
another purpose
life
has no purpose
and that's why it is so beautiful
hindus have called it to leela
a play
it is not even a game
[Music]
now in the west the word game has become
very very important
hundreds of books have been published
within two 2-3 years with the title
game
the master game
the ultimate game
the game people play
and so on so forth
but there is a difference between game
and play
hindus have called it to play not game
because even a game has something as a
purpose
a result to be attained
victory to be achieved
the opponent has to be conquered then a
play becomes a game
then it becomes serious
grown-ups
[Music]
play games
[Music]
children only play
just the very activity
is enough unto itself
it has an intrinsic end
there is no goal added to it
[Music]
life is a lila
it is a play
and the moment you are ready to play you
are enlightened
and the last answer i'll give you is a
little more complicated than that
from what i've been reading in science
uh friends of mine have written books on
this i've kind of stitched together some
theories and maybe there is a meaning to
life but it's not a very satisfying
purpose basically in physics you know
the arrow of time comes from entropy
second law of thermodynamics says that
entropy only goes up which means
disorder in the universe only goes up
which means concentrated free energy
only goes down and if you look at what
living things are living systems humans
plants civilizations what have you
these are systems that are locally
reversing entropy humans locally reverse
entropy because we have action but in
the process we globally accelerate
entropy until the heat depth of the
universe so you could come up with some
fanciful theory which i had which i like
that we're headed towards the heat depth
of the universe where there's no
concentrated energy where everything is
sort of the same energy level and
therefore we're all one thing we're
essentially indistinguishable and what
we are doing as living systems we're
accelerating getting to that state so
the more complex of a system you create
whether through computers and
civilization or through art and
mathematics or just through creating a
family you're actually accelerating the
heat depth of the universe so you're
pushing us towards this point where we
end up as one thing
but i think that's a kind of an
unsatisfying answer if you're looking
for personal meaning today in your life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you